so why do you not have a context again
so almond birthday right according to
Nina drunk logic
I need a minute disinfected as I was
trying to go to sleep
stay a hearty meal here
very close disinfected right
in the morning honestly
you're the dumbest person I'm all up in
my bread the main nobody [ __ ] way he
want it come and get it I be setting up
the critic Oh
are you hiding from the camera I did a
camera don't be shy I saw your photo
shoot yesterday rah you're pretty cool
yeah I saw your photo shoot yesterday
that's pretty cool yeah baby I love it
better got it obviously and like a
stomach ache in this public are you
excited for Hawaii the first time Oh
what the hell it's gonna be one I can
finally I'm gonna drown you over there
later that's disgusting how did she know
we were here hello
one deck it has the golden line I'm so
defined we're fine it's just like I look
like an idiot waiting for you ladies
that's how you always look it's all good
oh man I'm feeling like a kid again when
I'm back you know these tricks like a
rabbit it's magic I have it so check it
out we are over here at count see if and
we're about to get some okay so if you
guys know know what polka is polka is a
raw seafood prepared dish that a lot of
fine people eat it's one of my favorite
thing to eat out here so let's go ahead
and check that out
good idea
what do you have
no my dear Oh fire say I'm gonna try one
of these cubic hair-covered
why me Nadia none of this it's not this
way this way leaving this in this Taurus
Joris Loco where we where we at right
now we're at Leonard's big green one
it's a Portuguese donut this is a
malasada it's uh I think it's Filipino
it's covered in sugar deep-fried bread
stop covered in sugar and filled with
yummy goodness
all those others unfortunately I think
it's Filipino
question Oh
so what's the key to a successful
relationship excuse me shadi tell me
what your name is bad no I don't want
you to miss I was waiting when we said I
could never